I have to say you look you look very
nice
I know I know I look I decided to come
in a suit
apparently there's a blog a tumblr
account of some sort called Bill Hader
needs a change of clothes and and and
because you because you don't you don't
wear a suit often no I don't like it
this is like being sunburned right now I
don't like this is weird and so yeah
where I'm from Tulsa Oklahoma I wear
like just plaid shirts everywhere and I
dress like a farmer yeah and and what
you're saying is that fans notice this
or a fan or a group of fans notice this
and they started to that's the problem
with the Internet is that a few time
yeah to assemble and I think we have
examples of the website is that right so
basically how many times have you worn
that shirt that seems like it's the same
shirt every time seriously how many
times have you worn a more than that I'd
seem like that was my TV shirt for one
daddy's gonna go on television on the
preview is your wife is your wife no you
know I actually think that my wife this
is my wife is doing this website I think
my wife is in another room doing this
and then coming and going oh my god look
what they said about you
do something about that like today
happening that's really what your way
sounds like today this is really bumming
Dutch with the wife that's right that's
what this show does you do such great
impressions such great voices do try
them out on your wife
yeah what relax but no it was my wife
and I like watching Dateline the Keith
Morrison on Dateline that guy and I
don't know if you guys have seen him
he's the Dateline guys he tells these
horrible stories and very singsong like
oh yeah he's always talking about like a
horrible crime a horrible thing happened
someone's life but his demeanor doesn't
matter what he's so stoked about it
and yeah I hit one time he went he goes
but then there was that DNA oh that
pesky DNA
BET's he actually said that yeah I was
like no really do that around the house
where my wife would say we're gonna go
have Mexican food I go and she said you
should do that on the show and I was
like whew